need to make contact with the voodoo
boy's chief if you can swing it
all right all right straight to heavy
business
hmm now that'll be memo brigitte
be tough getting a word into her
huh i was led to believe you could
arrange anything
now that sounded like my third wife
every time she wanted a new purse
and that sounds like a spooky cult alias
have not had the pleasure of asking her
personally
but it is what everybody calls her doubt
the title has any real religious weight
though
voodoo boys play pretty fast and loose
with their haitian heritage
you really don't do any biz with them
not with the chefs
chef and priests and whatnot all got
dirigible-sized egos won't talk to lowly
me
but if you insist i can ask around try
to set something up
i'll just need some details first
uh got something they want
truly want to sell something to the vdbs
trust me they don't want it they don't
need it
they're isolated insulated they got
their own contracts
tech networks but have it your way
okay i'll see what i can do and get back
to you
don't
don't
work
[Music]
don't worry
[Music]
so
nice
uh
we will make them
suffer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
shampoo
attention
consider this your lucky day if you hear
pacifica call and you make sweet love to
it that is
got something for me well it's like i
said
whatever you're peddling the vdbs are
just not in the market
but they have another task that needs
doing so i volunteered you
do it well and you'll get your audience
with brigitte
okay so who do i talk to and how hit the
chapel on sloan
look for the altar inside someone will
touch you
nod to you something spooky
got it thanks
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's the hair isn't it we have had eyes
on you since
you entered
[Music]
someone finally gonna tell me about this
job i'm just the man in the middle
you will learn more sooner
interesting biz strategy you got in
pacifica no details no
names no one knows a thing your name we
know
that is enough screening me
see if i came along what kind of chrome
i got is some kind of test
most people we work with we knew as
babies
we know their angels you we do not know
wanna talk with bridget she hear someone
no
shopping center by the intersection go
to the butcher shop there
ask for placid he will tell you the
details
[Music]
you don't wanna [ __ ] with me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
hey
[Music]
so
well my creole's a bit rusty you balled
me london
[ __ ] luck right all those and i don't
know yours
mom
oh
you proceed
want to talk to your boss
you know i heard a few things about you
the voodoo boys best runners in town
at least that's what they say though
nobody really knows what you do on the
net
this is good i mean bleeding edge black
soft
corporate data heists waging war on
netwatch
but no one mentions chickens
i want to talk to bridget
but they send you to me and you'll tell
me more about the job
yes but not here follow me
pacifica a hotbed of controversy
you know pacifica well now
you guys aren't exactly great at rolling
out the welcome mat for outsiders
was to be its own city where suits were
burned
all the toys
pacifica's biggest ugliest temple to
breed
but never finished until last week
it was deserted empty but now
the animals crawled made a nest
museum
okay peter
[Music]
this way
let's go
[Music]
foreign
let me show you
animals before yeah a few times
you want the animals out of the gym
extinct
that why you hired me you learn
everything soon
i mean it makes no sense them being here
middle pacifica
no back up cut off
hell even badges don't patrol around
here
they're trying to provoke you make you
do something stupid
they do not leave how many we talking
about in there
teddy maybe more vinina
we talk here you sit
when do i see bridget you do job that
is fast
[Music]
whoa what the hell are you doing well at
least he's not likely to talk your ears
bloody
evelyn parker ring a bell
not one of us she did work for you once
got a feeling we're not going to become
best friends
no chemistry i will survive
why not send your own goons to the gym
this is not all we
as i've been working out for you what
good
good morning bad
you're calm shaman it is victor
you two know each other no no need
this hardware is [ __ ] you should replace
oh
so now you're a ripper doc too
is that at all relevant or just a cheap
scare tactic
i need you to be able i need no
this chip you have no signature
what is it
unimportant busted anyway
how got a bullet to the brain hasn't
worked since
that's how
you know you haven't asked about my
experience what i can do
we are not caught do not offer career
you do for us only one simple thing
once inside what do i do
the cam unit
[Music]
20 35 0 7
3 seconds before poof
we tried to learn where the cameo had
come from
van's definitely a custom job i see you
not know also
hey just trying to piece the facts
together you record all this on your own
local cam signals cop starts we capture
two all
but from inside the gym squat right
tech looks pretty advanced it doesn't
scream meathead to me
they watch it very close it is important
whatever i do
batman kelly updates another female
time for a break think you might be
needed
it will manage fine you focus
animals aren't the play here are they
they're hired muscles someone else
needed them
someone with a van full of netrunner
tech and that's where i come in
to sniff out who start with the
community
hide from all eyes only see the
situation
why what for you
now
another voice in your head just what the
ripper dock ordered
so aim to keep an eye on me
shows trust all right anything else i
should know
find out people name all they will show
you how to get inside the beast
my pay how much we talking and how am i
going to collect
and say you will not end this for cash
you win this for problem
2 g i am for us wijit can solve it
uh-huh except then i found out you need
me to be a bullet trap on enemy turf
that means my fees just gone up you will
see
no promise got it so i do this
and you put me in front of brigitte
right yes
[ __ ] at end of the hall go down my
people will let you pass
we are done